ils sont quelques centaines ce mercredi
soir à avoir bravé dans le calme le
couvre-feu pour rendre hommage aux deux
manifestants anti brutalité policière
tuée la veille dans la ville
le suspect un adolescent blanc de 17 ans
hier soir un jeune homme de 17 ans
originaire d'antioche en illinois a été
impliqué dans l'utilisation d'armes à
feu pour réserver pardon pour résoudre
un conflit et en conséquence deux
personnes sont mortes ce n'est pas une
intervention policière
je ne pense pas non plus que ce soit une
action des manifestants c'est l'action
de personnes qui ont été impliquées une
fois l'heure du couvre-feu passé
impliqué dans des activités illégales et
qui ont amené la violence au sein de
cette communauté
un drame résultat d'un cocktail explosif
mêlant émeutiers policiers et groupes
d'autodéfense un contexte de tension
extrême qui fait suite à la diffusion
d'une vidéo montrant un homme noir
blessé grièvement lors de son
interpellation
jacob blake un père de famille de 29 ans
a été touché de sept balles dans le dos
tiré à bout portant par un policier
blanc
selon les autorités l'homme qui pourrait
être paralysé à vie avait un couteau
dans sa voiture depuis malgré un
couvre-feu le déploiement de 250 soldats
de la garde nationale et les appels au
calme lancés par la famille de jacob
black
les rassemblements sont émaillés chaque
nuit de violences
des violences que s'est empressée de
condamner donald trump mettant l'accent
sur les débordements des manifestants et
promettant d'appliquer son slogan de
campagne pour la présidentielle du 3
novembre à savoir rétablir la loi et
l'ordre
nous ne tolérerons pas les pillages les
incendies criminels la violence et
l'anarchie dans les rues américaines le
président américain par ailleurs annoncé
l'envoi de policiers de soldats de la
garde nationale supplémentaires à
kenosha mercredi soir contrairement nuit
précédente les forces de l'ordre étaient
pourtant invisibles aux abords de la
manifestation